Eric Schlosser author of reefer madness
all it says about you under your picture
on the dust dust jacket is Eric
Schlosser is a correspondent for The
Atlantic Monthly and the author of Fast
Food Nation he is currently at work on a
book about the American prison system
was that your idea to have so little
biographical information
it wasn't solely my idea but I've really
tried as a writer to put the subject
matter before me and and there are a lot
of writers who I really admire whose
whose life story is part of the process
I love Hunter Thompson's work for
example but for me I'm really trying to
take the stories I write about the
subjects I write about and make them you
know first and foremost but I don't have
anything I feel I need to hide or any no
convictions yet or nothing no no
terrible scandals the jihad you made a
splash with this book Fast Food Nation
when did it come out and what's it about
it came out two years ago and it's an
investigative work about the fast food
industry in America and its impact on
agriculture our economy our labor force
and how we eat and what we look like
have you changed your eating habits
since you did it not that much I still
pretty much eat what I did before I just
don't eat them eat these foods in the
same places I don't go to the big fast
food chains anymore why I just don't
want to give them my money having
learned how they operated having learned
about their business practices I choose
not to spend my money there but I I
still like french fries I just buy them
from different venues what's the
number-one thing you don't like about
these big businesses that run these
fast-food places I think once they got
big to a certain point there they really
lost touch with a kind of a core
humanity they treat workers as though
they're completely interchangeable parts
of their operating machinery they really
have not taken responsibility for the
impact that they have on our
agricultural system and what's happening
in their supplier slaughterhouses etc so
you know there's a chain that I eat out
in California called in and out and it's
a fast food chain
serves pretty much the same foods but
they pay decent wages it's real food and
I think in the fast food industry they
reached a certain size and and lost
touch with some basic human values are
they a success they've been a huge
success but I think that their success
is beginning to wane I think the
American fast-food industry reached its
peak around the year 2000 and is now
starting to decline and McDonald's lost
money for the first time in its history
last year and I think people are going
to still want fast food but the era of
these gigantic centralized restaurant
chains serving food that tastes
everywhere exactly the same I think
maybe ending and and smaller companies
are going to prosper so I don't I don't
think that McDonald's is going to
disappear but I don't know that it's
gonna grow it anywhere near the rate it
has in the past and it may even shrink
in the book that we're talking about
today reefer madness you break it up in
three sections pornography and marijuana
but the middle one is the Strawberry
Fields yeah did you happen to get onto
that through your book on Fast Food
Nation it actually happened the other
way around
I started out writing about migrant
workers for the Atlantic Monthly and
spent almost a year of looking at
migrant workers and following the
harvest and it was after the editors at
Rolling Stone read that piece in which
had taken all these complex economic and
historical forces and told them through
the story of your strawberry and where
it comes from the editors at Rolling
Stone asked me to do the same thing for
fast food to look behind the counter and
take this commodity that we all take for
granted and show where it comes from and
the systems behind it before you went to
the fields the the California farm
fields and the migrant workers where
were you where'd you live I live in New
York City how long have you lived there
I was born there and I lived there my
first 18 years then went to university
in graduate school and living in Vermont
briefly and now live in New York City
where'd you go school I went to
Princeton undergraduate and got a
graduate degree in history from Oxford
in why Vermont Vermont will seem like a
nice quiet place to try and be a
playwright and a novelist but it wasn't
a very successful experiment I started
out as a fiction writer and was
unsuccessful in that and moved to New
York City worked for a film company for
a while and was not very happy with that
got an opportunity to write a brief
piece for The Atlantic Monthly they ran
it and then gave me a bigger assignment
and that's pretty much what I've been
doing ever since other than the obvious
that your books didn't sell why didn't
you make it as an almost I don't know
you know I may be like the comedian who
who still wants to do Hamlet but I but
part of me thinks I'm better at fiction
and and and and that's sort of writing
that I am at this but I can't say why
maybe I was a lousy novelist or maybe
maybe it's just the timing wasn't right
it's hard to say I tried this book a
reefer madness I hoped and tried to get
published before Fast Food Nation but
publishers weren't interested in it so
it's it's hard to say how much is the
quality of the material and and how much
is the marketplace and what the
marketplace wants why did they get
interested after Fast Food Nation I'd
have to ask them I mean I think that
these subjects are relevant I try to
write about things I care about and I
think are important but you know times
change in the in the paperback edition
of Fast Food Nation at the end in trying
to explain the success of that book I'd
like to think it's the brilliance of my
prose but realistically I think that if
if Fast Food Nation had been published
five or six years earlier I I don't know
if it would have found a readership it's
very hard to say you know why something
succeeds or fails in the moment I think
people wrote beautiful books that were
published on September 12th or in
September of 2001 and no one will ever
hear of those books I have friends
who've written wonderful books that
don't get reviewed so I
I can't really explain the success I
just try to write about what I care
about and see what happens Princeton and
Oxford yeah well what was the family
life before you got there like and what
were your parents like they still around
my parents were still alive
my parents are wonderful I admire my
father more than any man I've ever met
and I had a very happy childhood I was
you know compliance he's in retirement
but he was a television executive full
name Herbert schlosser zetterberg
Schlosser of NBC so Herbert's foster of
NBC yeah and you know at this point I
say no kidding
I mean I grew up with that name rather
prominent uh-huh in the business tell
our audience what he did he was a
television executive for many years he
rose up the ranks and he was head of NBC
at one point and then you know I feel
like the film network could have been
based in some ways on on what happened
to my father my father represented a
very old-fashioned notion of public
service and in television and you know
he was involved in all kinds of
interesting shows like laugh-in and
comedies but he also had a very strong
belief and in public service and
documentaries and and his departure from
NBC I think was was a turning point not
because he was leaving but but that
period was a turning point in which
ratings became paramount in which rady's
ratings were suddenly being published in
the newspaper and the way that nobody
outside the industry ever thought about
them and I think that you know those
notions of fairness like the Fairness
Doctrine and the idea of having a
documentary in primetime about anything
except Michael Jackson is inconceivable
today but it was a very tough business
very cutthroat business but in watching
my father and growing up I felt like he
was a real man of honor and integrity
and was able to succeed without being a
slime ball like a lot of people are in
that business quickfacts
when was he head of NBC he was head of
NBC in the early 1970s and I think he he
left around 1970
eat something like that and how old a
man is he today he is 77 what's he doing
he's in semi-retirement he's an advisor
on various telecommunications issues he
worked for RCA after that and was you
know continuing to get involved in new
businesses and was helped set up the A &
E channel one of the first big cable
channels and has been was involved in
the internet businesses and he's a very
vital active person but what was
interesting for me is you know people
have accused Fast Food Nation of being
anti corporate an anti business and I'm
really not that way at all I mean I grew
up in that kind of household and it's
just the kind of corporate sensibility
of the of the 50s 60s and 70s very very
different from that of the 80s and 90s
and so you know I grew up where profits
were important but you know household
where profits were concerned and
important but they didn't you know they
weren't the the only criteria and there
were other values that mattered as well
how about your mom my mother has been
involved in in the dance world she
worked for many years of the Martha
Graham Dance Company in New York City
and you know III had an incredibly
fortunate upbringing in a sense that my
father's work was interesting it it
encompassed both news and and the
entertainment worlds and and my mother
has a very literary vent and and and
where we were as my father would be
reading history my mother would be
reading novels and fiction and her
father was a was a painter so I had a I
had a very I had a very stimulating
upbringing very very fortunate well
define kind of broadly your I don't know
if you call it
political views but your attitude
because you got some pretty sensitive
subjects here the marijuana sales and
the prison sentences and all that stuff
and the migrant workers and also the
porno industry defined ever all what
what you think define I think what I
think about the black what the world
just about the world in general how do
you approach the you know what would you
call yourself remember a political party
a liberal politically politically
independent I mean it sounds corny but
but a lot of my work and having studied
American history extensively is trying
to make America live up to its own
ideals and and to try to reconcile what
we say we are and who we say we are with
how we actually live and and and how the
government behaves so again you know
I've been accused of being anti
corporate anti-business a socialist a
communist and yet in my own mind there
have been periods in our history where
my own view of the world isn't that
unusual isn't that odd you know in terms
of Fast Food Nation the kinds of
recommendations that I called for at the
end of the book would have been in
keeping with what Eisenhower would have
had in place if you look at the
Eisenhower era we have strict antitrust
enforcement high proportion of labor
union membership you know graduated
income tax so you know in defending
myself against critics and and
particularly now with this
administration I would say that you know
the people who are running the Congress
and the White House are radicals and and
I don't feel as though I am on some
issues I'm very liberal politically I
spent a year looking at murder for the
Atlantic Monthly and wrote about the
victims rights movement and you know the
National Rifle Association distributed
that piece and you know really liked the
piece so hopefully if you had a complex
view of the world it's not easy to easy
to categorize you but but certainly what
I've tried to do with my investigative
work is tell stories that the mainstream
media is ignoring for one reason or
another and particularly to bring the
voices of people who may ignore to the
public whether it's migrant workers
whether it's you know the meatpacking
workers I wrote about in Fast Food
Nation and so I guess it would take
someone else to to category to
categorize me neatly
ideally two different people with two
different political points of view could
read one of my books get something from
it come away feeling differently I mean
I try I try at the end of each section
or a try at the end of the book to
propose solutions to to make
recommendations but the bulk of the work
is investigative reporting and and
hopefully is balanced and tries to be
fair you interviewed a woman by the name
of 9a hartley nina hartley nina hartley
you know ni na yeah we had somebody at
work too at our place called 9i say it
goes banging forth who was she and why'd
you interviewer well when I interviewed
her if you had you know passed by us in
the restaurant you would have thought
that she was a an attractive aerobics
instructor or maybe you know a sociology
graduate student but she's actually one
of the most legendary and and successful
porn actresses in America and very smart
very articulate and she described for me
the labor practices of the of the
industry the the three essays in this
book reefer madness you know are about
black markets and in a way it's a
business book so in in the in the
pornography section nina hartley was a
very very good guide to some of the
labor practices in the industry and so
why would you interview her what would
you learn from her I learned you know
what the wage rates are I learned what
the life is like for for people who who
work in this industry for the women who
work in this industry she wasn't the
only porn actress who I interviewed she
was the most articulate and and she was
one who I who I put in the book but you
know I was trying to get a sense of what
is it like to do this job she's a woman
who you know is extremely sophisticated
has read widely and political theory
considers herself a feminist and is very
articulate most porn actresses don't fit
that bill and she has a rosier view of
this work and of this industry than
other people I met but but she was she
provided a you know a lot of insight
into how it works and who gets paid and
where
money goes and etc etc no unions in the
porn world yet did I read that you you
say that there's something like eleven
thousand porn films a year produced
eleven thousand videos produced yeah
different different titles some of those
may be you know old material resupplies
together but that's that's an
extraordinary number of titles what are
there you haven't know the number of
movies that are made every year to go I
mean it's not 150 there's probably about
a hundred hundred and fifty something
like that but eleven thousand videos a
year different but are they stories most
of them are not stories most of them are
just stains scenes of sex cut with one
another but you know if there's been a
huge growth in the production of porn
the VCR you know took it out of a dull
theaters and put it into people's homes
and it's clearly a product that people
like a lot and want to buy how many
people buy it a year that's a good
question
I I don't know the answer to that but
but clearly a lot of them I mean the the
the video store rentals the number of
titles that are rented I think is seven
hundred and seven hundred ninety million
a year so when you figure the adult
population at about 200 million that's a
lot of people renting porn blockbusters
what is their rule off buster won't
carry porn so this has been a real boon
to independent video stores at a time
when they're competing with blockbuster
fiercely these are you know these are
films that they can rent and earn money
from at a time when blockbuster is
driving them out of business left and
right so oddly enough you know the
mom-and-pop video stores rely a lot more
on the revenues from porn than the big
companies whose Rubin Sterman Rubens
German was a figure who played a central
role in the rise of the pornography
industry and you know every industry has
these these great robber barons these
these magnates there was a history book
I'd love to read aloft the author I
can't remember but the the title of it
was the Lords of creation and it was
about their Rockefellers and the
Carnegie's who built great American
industries and Rubens Thurman was
for the porn industry and what struck me
about him
what's his picture but is this him
that's him whereas Hugh Hefner and Larry
Flynt courted publicity and love to be
in the paper Rubin Sterman who was much
wealthier and more powerful didn't like
any publicity would appear in public
often with wearing disguises like here
you like here he's got a scratch on that
marks nose on and he run this worldwide
porn empire from the suburb of Shaker
Heights and suburb of Cleveland Ohio
now you interviewed him says i
interviewed but he's no longer a lot
he's no longer alive he he started out
as a comic book salesman in Cleveland in
the early 1960s late 1950s and basically
was a successful upper middle-class
businessman until he started to sell a
few girlie magazines and branched out
from that one thing led to another and
created this gigantic porn Empire I
interviewed him once he finally had been
sent to prison by the federal government
the the federal government started
prosecuting him in the early 1960s and
it took almost 30 years for them to
really put him away but I interviewed
him at the end of his life what are the
rules about pornography that's a very
good question I don't know that there
are any rules at the moment I mean right
now the federal federal law forbids the
production or distribution of obscene
material that's a law that was passed in
1873 but the question is what's obscene
and what's not I mean we all have a
fairly good notion of what a murderer is
or what an armed robbery is that's a
that's something few of us would argue
about but an obscenity crime is unique
in that it occurs in the mind so
whatever a jury says is obscene is
obscene the federal government has tried
very hard to keep hardcore porn off the
market and in the 1980s in particular
under the Reagan and Bush
administration's really tried to crack
down on porn unfortunately juries even a
very conservative communities kept on
saying hard
Court porn wasn't obscene it's it's kind
of a gray area right now but
nevertheless some very very big
corporations are making a lot of money
off of pornography and in telling the
story of this industry you know Ruben
Sterman being the the robber baron who
really gets it into being a gigantic
worldwide industry he passes from the
scene and the people who are making a
lot of money for porn now have names
like AOL Time Warner Hilton Marriott
they are distributing via satellite and
cable and in their hotel rooms material
that could easily have gotten you sent
to prison in the early 1960s maybe even
in the early 1970s hardcore porn defined
hardcore porn would be sexually explicit
material in which the sex acts are
unmistakably real as opposed to
simulated you know r-rated you know
Hollywood films maybe they're actually
having sex maybe they're not but in
hardcore they really are and it's
visibly so have you done any analysis of
how much money comes into either the
cable industry or the direct satellite
industry yeah I mean these are these are
rough estimates about four hundred and
sixty five hundred million a year of
porn his throat is sold via cable and
satellite and upwards of 200 million via
hotels so that's a it's a lot of money
Sterman go back to the beginning where
was he from and how did you get into the
comic book business yeah he just you
know he was he was in the Army Air Force
during World War two got involved in a
candy distributorship in Cleveland met
somebody who had access to remaindered
comic books these were comic books that
were supposed to be returned to the
publisher and shredded but he got them
cheaply somehow and was able to sell
them for a very small amount of money
and he just set up this magazine
distribution network in Cleveland going
to local candy stores and mom-and-pop
stores with his remaindered comic books
and later crossword puzzle books etc etc
and he just happened to be in the right
place
in the right time or ultimately maybe
the wrong place in the wrong time he had
a distribution network and at that very
time playboy was successful and there
were a lot of imitators of Playboy and
this was very risque to show women
without their shirts on and his
distribution network was perfect for
selling these girlie magazines so he
started out in the Midwest distributing
girlie magazines and gradually his
empire grew and as films became part of
the porn world he put in these peeps
which showed you know a film loop of
sexual activity and that was incredibly
profitable and when he put him in he put
them in the back of the store and in a
booth with the door that could be locked
and there had been stag films you know
dating back to the beginning of the 20th
century that was shown at college
fraternities and Kiwanis Clubs and the
the people allowed men to have a stag
film for one and close the door or lock
the door and fee quarters into this
machine and it was incredibly incredibly
profitable so within a relatively brief
period of time Sterman came to dominate
the production and the distribution of
hardcore pornography not just in the
United States but also throughout the
world in Western Europe as well you
suggest some hypocrisy among
conservatives well not all conservatives
but but one of the things I look at in
the porn section is the the public
morality and the desire to stipe to
stamp out Vice and these these moral
Crusades and the underlying reality not
just about how people are are really
behaving but even within the same person
you see this public desire to stamp out
vice and then this private desire to
indulge in it I mean one one example
would be father Bruce Ritter who was a
member of President Reagan's Meese
Commission to investigate pornography
and Ritter was very adamant by day that
homosexuality should be included in the
Commission's purview and that
homosexuality should be officially
condemned and by night he was cruising
for young male prostitutes and a
again you see in our history this this
kind of obsession with pornography in
some people being combined with a with a
real desire to indulge in it now I'm not
saying that of all conservatives by any
means or of all critics of pornography
there are a lot of people who criticize
it and and rightly so on its on its
content but when you look at America we
have some of the toughest laws on
pornography in the Western world but we
watch more porn we produce more porn you
know we have a pornographic culture and
the same is true you know for the other
section of the book on marijuana we have
some of the toughest marijuana laws in
the Western world I mean you can get a
life sentence without parole for a
first-time marijuana offense but we grow
more marijuana you know we smoke more
pot we we write more songs about pot I
think that speaks to very deeply
conflicted American psyche and culture
on these issues go back to Bruce Ritter
and father Bruce Ritter how did you know
that he cruised at night trying to find
homes he had to he had to step down from
he was the head of Covenant House and it
was revealed I believe one of the young
men Covenant house was a place in New
York City for Runaways a catholic
charity and one of the Runaways you know
came out publicly and said that he had
been paid to have sex with father Ritter
and there was a scandal that involved
his behavior and he had to he had to
step down you also write about a man
named Charles Keating
yeah and Charles Keating was a was a
it's interesting that a lot of these
people come from roughly the same place
I mean Larry and Larry Flynt was from
Ohio
Reuben Thurman was from Ohio Charles
Keating who became the nation's biggest
anti-pornography crusader also from Ohio
and starting the late 1950s onward he
was really the the foremost American
opponent of sexually explicit material
but his interest in the subject you know
from my point of view just seemed a
little bit excessive and in the book I
quote from one of his appearances in
Congress where you know in order to make
his point and his organization you know
making its point about pornography
they're reading into the Congressional
Record in front of young people who have
come to the Congress that data to watch
these hearings you know relatively
explicit sexual material and he wound up
being involved in the collapse of
Lincoln Savings and Loan you know a huge
Bank scandal in the 1980s and I think
ultimately he's the Keating five what
they yeah who was the Keating five and I
think ultimately you know a lot of the
Crusaders against vice are human too and
and I think should be more forgiving of
human faults you know he was in glass
houses that that old that old quote and
yet we have these periodic campaigns
against Vice that are very moralistic
and very unforgiving ultimately I mean
I'm not justifying people who smoke too
much pot or people who make pornography
that's you know upsetting but but this
desire to be purer than pure and and
condemn others for their personal habits
is very American and if you look at the
history of this country we were founded
by Puritans I mean literally by Puritans
but at the same time this country has a
very rebellious and iconoclastic history
and tradition and I think through all
these issues you see this ongoing battle
between the Puritan part of our culture
and and the very rebellious and
iconoclastic you know dissenting
tradition that we have there are some
references I was looking forward here in
that chapter about Richard Nixon and
Jews and his attitude yeah about the
Jews in pornography this guy was
actually about marijuana oh I'm sorry I
wasn't it when we
and when marijuana was really being
debated in the late 1960s and early
1970s a Nixon appointed a commission to
investigate what should be done about
marijuana in America and whether it
should be legalized or kept illegal or
decriminalized and when the Commission
that was appointed came out in favor of
decriminalization he blamed it on the
Jews and and that never happened those
recommendations were never were never
carried out but back to the porn chapter
of Phillip Hartley who was hot I'm sorry
Philip Carvel Harvey Harvey Philip
Harvey is a very interesting figure who
today runs one of the largest mail-order
probably the largest mail-order
pornography companies in America but he
runs it from North Carolina and he leads
a he leads a double life he's a very
articulate very intelligent Harvard
educated expert in family planning and
he uses many much of the profit from his
pornography empire to fuel charitable
work throughout the developing countries
and started out selling you know birth
control and that same 1873 law that I
mentioned earlier the Comstock tact that
forbade obscene material from being
distributed also forbade the
distribution of information about birth
control through the male's so Harvey
started selling condoms and other birth
control information through the male's
fought the father government in the
early 1970s to do that gradually
branched out to sexually explicit
materials and he's like a character out
of a play by George Bernard Shaw in the
sense that he is so Hurley seems so
conservative personally and and seems
very patrician and seems like an
academic and you would never think in a
million years that here is one of the
most influential and wealthy
pornographers in the United States and
he he you know believes in what he does
he uses the profits for the most part
you know for good ends and he takes the
the products that he sells and subjects
it to you know a commission of sex
therapists to make sure there's nothing
you
horrible about it and he's an
interesting interesting character did
you interview him I did I interviewed
him and he he stood up to the to the
Bush administration the first Bush
administration's war on pornography
because the government realized that
they couldn't get juries to convict
people for obscene material they came up
with a strategy of indicted people in in
many just many different districts at
once so Harvey was indicted again and
again and the strategy was not to win
any individual case but to come with so
many indictments that you'd have to plea
bargain and go out of business because
you know the government can afford to
depress eight or nine cases at once but
most individuals can't defend themselves
in that many venues excuse me you uh you
do pay an interesting picture of
Hillsboro North Carolina yeah how many
people there work in the the Kent I
can't remember the exact number but it's
I think it's the biggest private
employer in this little town five
thousand residents in this chapter you
say yeah I don't know where the figure
is on the number a lot of them this is a
outfit pH pH pH II in karate and this is
Phil Harvey's huge mail order operation
it's run out of Hillsboro North Carolina
selling home selling unit at selling
hardcore videos selling sexual devices
selling books vary the kinds of things
that you find in a New York City sex
shop but he argues that this is the most
socially responsible way to sell this
material you're not imposing it on
anyone you you know you're not you're
not putting it into anyone's face the
marketing or anything like that it's
done but it's done through the mail it's
done very discreetly and this is a very
conservative community that doesn't seem
to mind his business and and most of his
employees are women and did you see that
I mean yeah you know I wouldn't I went
into the warehouse and I just saw this
vast high-tech warehouse in which you
know all these packages are being sorted
and very dainty white haired Southern
women are handling material that you
would not
and then we'll really think that they
would be handling and packaging and
boxing but I think you know if you visit
that operation you you get a sense of
how much a part of the mainstream in
America this material has become and
these objects have become in his own
area juries won't convict him because
they believe that adults should be able
to see what they want to see in the
privacy of of their own homes this is a
far cry from the early 1960s again when
Ruben Thurman was starting out Lenny
Bruce the comedian was imprisoned for
saying a few swear words which I won't
say in this show during his nightclub
act it's remarkable what you could be
prosecuted for in the in the early 60s
and what you'd see on HBO today is far
more explicit than what people were sent
to prison for 30 35 years ago
you think of fellow rather strongly in
the back by the name of Ross Felder yes
who was he rich Ross Felder was a was a
federal agent and in Cleveland with the
organized crime strike force and he
became intrigued with Rubens German this
this porn magnate of Cleveland because
no one really knew much about him and
the FBI had been trying for more than a
decade to get Sterman indicted and
convicted on obscenity charges but the
more that Ross Felder learned about
Stern's operation the more he thought
that Sterman was a multi-million dollar
tax sheet and Ross Felder was a criminal
investigator for the IRS and in order to
avoid giving money to the government
Sturman had created an unbelievably
Byzantine corporate structure the sort
of thing that Enron created a couple of
decades later to shift monies from
various off through various offshore
corporations and offshore banks and
Thurmond felt that he had no obligation
to subsidize the government that was
trying to put him into prison so Ross
Felder started investigating Sterman I
think in 1975 and spent almost 20 years
pursuing him dogged Lee throughout the
world to build a case against him and
eventually did bring him down
a very honorable rustbelt or a very good
guy very honorable guy and really to me
a model public servant so he wasn't
after the porn side of this he was after
the tax cheats III don't think that that
rich is a great fan of pornography but
what offended him was the idea here was
a multi-million dollar tax cheat and and
a very arrogant one Sterman had a lot of
hubris he after the first time the FBI
raided his his warehouse in 63 he
responded by suing J Edgar Hoover now
this was at the height of Hoover's power
so Sturman was a very arrogant guy who
really believed in his own intellect and
his own abilities and it's it's
remarkable how many times Stormin did
beat the federal government and how
close he came even to winning the tax
case you know as I write in the book he
tried to he tried to tamper with the
jury and after spending you know almost
two decades pursuing Rubin Sturman Russ
Felder is quite blunt now about how if
Sterman had managed to tamper with the
jury and there'd been a mistrial
Sherman might have walked free and never
gone to prison what was the story about
the juror that was his second wife
picked out and tried out in the middle
of the trial Sherman had a very
attractive young life and there was a
young male juror who received a note
from her and the juror had no idea this
was the lead defendants wife but the
note suggested they meet later on and he
wound up going out to dinner with her
and she clearly offered him she tried to
persuade him to to find Sterman not
guilty and it's quite possible that a
different juror this juror this juror
wound up voting to convict but a
different juror might have accepted
money or sexual favors in return for a
not guilty plea and that would have been
the end of the government case and and
Sturman might have walked free did you
talk to either the juror or the second
wife no I didn't in in focusing on
Sherman and his career I again this is
this this is about the the sections
about pornography
it's business it's a business piece it's
it's a the book is a business book and I
really tried not to get too involved in
his personal life I never sought out his
children I never sought out his ex-wives
I wasn't as interested in that personal
side of his life but just in how he
built this Empire go back to the she was
she was later sent to prison though for
her role in tampering with the jury so
so he did catch her on this they did
catch her on this and and so you know in
writing about family members I tried to
write about them to the degree that you
know they were convicted of various
crimes but not to get into his personal
life you say the rich Ross daughter took
20 years almost 20 years how many times
was Sturman tried he was he was trial or
anything like I can't I can't remember
the number but it seemed as though he
was tried every two years or so how many
times a convict on on federal obscenity
on state obscenity charges again and
again he was tried for the content of
the material that he was selling and he
beat the rap every single time and every
time that he beat the rap his stature
grew even larger in the porn industry he
was adamant about beating the federal
government and he would subsidize the
legal fees of other people in the
industry even if they were rivals if
they would stand up to the government
and it wasn't until the end when he'd
already been convicted on tax charges
that he decided to plead guilty to an
obscenity charge in Las Vegas and so if
you if you think of the federal
government tried to get him on obscenity
charges dating back to 1963 and it took
it took 28 years for them to get him on
a single charge
he had brilliant lawyers and he was
willing to fight you know any any
indictment in the middle that you talk
about him moving money offshore yeah and
I want to ask you about that what are
the rules today I know you moved him to
Swiss banks he also moved it to
Lichtenstein yeah so what today and I
think the Virgin Islands in there
somewhere yeah what is what are the
rules today about moving money offshore
well you know an IRS agent would be
better worse than me to tell you what
the taxation implications are but
Sterman really pioneer
all kinds of very innovative methods of
money laundering and you know by trying
to get the money offshore he didn't want
to just park it offshore he wanted to be
able to use it in the United States so
he would set up various corporations or
establishments he did it in
Liechtenstein he did it in Panama he did
it in the Cayman Islands and then those
offshore corporations would be making
investments in the United States and the
IRS doesn't have access to offshore
corporations and and their books but you
know towards the end of my book I talked
about how what Sterman was doing and
pioneering many corporations in the
United States you know I'm sure they've
looked at the tax law very carefully are
not breaking the law on doing it but the
strategy has been similar to avoid
paying taxes in the United States
there's been a big boom in the last ten
years of what it called inversion
transactions which is American companies
that have all their facilities in the
United States taking out a mailbox
overseas and calling themselves foreign
corporations to avoid paying tax in
sternman's case he didn't want to pay
taxes result for philosophical reasons
he didn't want to give this government
that was trying to put him in prison a
single penny but I think he also wanted
to enjoy as much of his money as he
could he died again in what year he died
I think in 1997 he died in a federal
prison and by then you know when I met
him he he was like a proud and deposed
head of state he claimed to be
completely broke although that's never
really been proven if he was I mean he
might have had millions of dollars
parked on offshore accounts that Ross
Felder and the IRS never found and the
porn industry had moved on I mean it had
become corporate it had these
relationships with the satellites and
the cable companies and
Sturman increasingly seemed like a
figure from the shadowy past there were
allegations that
Sturman had links to organized crime to
the Gambino family and so by the time I
met him he was a very bright very
articulate lonely man in a prison in
Kentucky whose time had clearly passed
want to go to another section but first
when I ask you a couple philosophical
questions about the book long detailed
source notes in the back yeah but
relatively short book is that your
philosophy well I've got to be careful
that the the source notes never become
longer than the actual book I believe in
transparency as much as possible with
the work and and the same was true with
Fast Food Nation for readers who are
interested in something I've written who
want to read more about it the source
notes are there for readers who don't
believe what I'm saying and want to see
where that came from and check it for
themselves the source notes are there
for people who might think of suing me
for libel the source notes are there so
I'm trying to trying to be very careful
as a journalist and also not rely on
unnamed sources and and and and expect
the reader just to take my word that
these things are true if you look at
Fast Food Nation and you look at this
book there are there are a lot of things
in it they're potentially controversial
that I haven't been written about
extensively before and I'm not expecting
anyone to just take my word on it and
and so I'm gonna try to keep the source
notes under control for the next book
but I feel you know there are no
footnotes in the texts of people who
want to read the book and never look at
the source notes that's just fine but
people who are curious or questioning or
litigious can can look at the source
notes and and and see that it's all it's
all there where I got things I'll put it
in context it's about 60 pages out of
300 overall
the other thing would ask you about is
this book cover yeah I've never seen one
like it yeah it's this I'm holding it
sideways so the audience can read it his
idea was that not mine but I like it I
like that I like that there's that pull
quote from the book which gives you on
the cover you know one of the central
themes of the book which is that these
black markets and the mainstream are
pretty much linked together and I try in
the book to show that this is one
country America and
there's something artificial about
dividing these markets from the rest of
our markets how big is the black market
it's huge and an economists agree that
it's really been growing since around
1970 but what its actual size is nobody
knows I mean I I try to use statistics
from a conservative Austrian economist
who is doing work for the International
Monetary Fund his estimates are eight to
ten percent of our gross domestic
product that would be about a trillion
dollars when the IRS in 1998 looked at
how much money you know people were
evading in taxes they came up with a
estimate of 200 billion dollars was not
being paid in taxes and that would mean
about a trillion and a half dollars in
income was not being reported and that
doesn't include illegal activity so it's
huge it's gigantic who is Mark young
mark young was a hippie biker who I
wrote about in the marihuana section of
the book and he's no saint but but he's
certainly no serial killer where's he
from he's from Indiana where an Indian
in Indianapolis and he was involved in a
marijuana deal he didn't grow the pot he
didn't sell the pot or distribute it but
he introduced a grower to a distributor
and took a cut on some of their sales
and when this marijuana growing
operation was shut down mark young
refused to cooperate with the government
refused to testify against anybody
refused to admit that he was guilty he's
a very proud marijuana smoker and as a
result for his first marijuana crime he
was sentenced to life without parole and
sent to a very scary federal
penitentiary in Kansas did you go see
him I did and that was that was quite an
experience Leavenworth Penitentiary is a
very scary building and it was designed
to be that way it was the first federal
penitentiary and it's very strange its
architecture is modeled on that of the
US Capitol building but it's it's this
you know Sidel the the Capitol building
is like our symbol of freedom but
somehow they've transformed that into a
symbol of very it's a scary place
very
keep on saying that an old prison and
very dangerous very you know that's
where they send convicted international
terrorists and and killers and here was
this hippie biker there for pot deal how
old is he he was oh she's probably about
48 now he was in his mid-30s when he got
sent to prison he wound up after after I
wrote about him for the Atlantic Monthly
and after the article came out his life
sentence was reduced to 12 years which
is still longer than the typical
convicted killer spends in prison in the
United States so in the marijuana
section I'm trying to come to terms with
how do we punish someone more for
marijuana in America than for killing
somebody with a gun you list a number of
conservatives that are for the
decriminalization of marijuana is there
any way to put people in classes as to
what they think about smoking marijuana
well you know it's it's it's generally a
very certain kind of moralistic
conservative who has led the prohibition
of marijuana and is in favor of these
very tough sentences the current drug
czar John Waters is in favor of
increasing some of the penalties for
marijuana and yet there are other
conservatives who come from a much more
libertarian a tradition and not as much
of a moralistic tradition like William
Buckley Milton Friedman George Schultz
who have called for the
decriminalization of marijuana and and
the traditional political labels don't
always apply when it comes to the war on
drugs a lot of the tough legislation was
eagerly sponsored by Liberal Democrats
and we've had one president who's
admitted to having a joint in his mouth
which was Bill Clinton and more people
were sent to prison and arrested for
marijuana during the Clinton
administration than during any other
presidency more people were sent to
prison while Clinton was president than
during any of any other president say
you say I'll just read him off to the
third of the population and smoke
marijuana that 20 million smoked at a
year that two men smoked it every day
and that half of the I mean most of the
marijuana's in this country's grown in
the America's heartland yeah yeah I mean
Indiana was all over this yeah look I
mean the reason that I wrote you know
the way that the book works is that
marijuana is a black market commodity
illegal immigrants are black market
labor and then pornography is an example
of how a little black market becomes
mainstream like you know I wrote about
marijuana and not cocaine for a number
of reasons it's the most widely used
illegal drug in the United States it's
the most popular and it's also the one
that we produce here you can't blame
this problem on Colombian cartels this
is an all-american crop it's being grown
you know not just in Northern California
or Hawaii which is or Kentucky which are
the popular stereotypes of marijuana
growing but I wrote about a very
profitable marijuana farm in Indiana
it's being grown widely in Illinois in
Missouri and no one knows for sure but
but I believe and I contend in the book
that most of the marijuana being grown
in the United States is coming from the
farm belt and it some people believe
it's our largest cash crop in the United
States corn is our corn crop is worth
about nineteen billion dollars some
people think our marijuana crop may be
worth as much as 25 billion but in any
event it's huge because you know apples
which is our biggest fruit I mean that's
about a billion dollars a year and so
even if it's five billion or ten billion
in marijuana
that's a huge huge American industry and
and again coming out of the heartland
you say between a hundred and two
hundred thousand commercial growers in
the United States that's a that's a
rough estimate that comes from an old
federal drug investigative report but
clearly if twenty million people are
smoking at a year you need a lot of
people to grow it and the the estimate
of two million a day smoking it and 20
million a year these come from
government surveys in which people are
asked if they smoke marijuana and most
likely that under States the number
considerably because given the marijuana
laws that we have now I think a fair
number of people aren't going to tell
the government sincerely and honestly if
they're if they're using marijuana
growing it if they arrested you or me
and we had smoked it yeah
what's the Israel mandatory sentence no
it's a very unusual type of crime in the
sense that a marijuana crime can be
subject to local law state law and
federal law simultaneously and as a
matter of fact if you're arrested with
some marijuana and found innocent under
local law you're under your state law
the federal government could still
prosecute you for the same marijuana and
send you to prison I mean I write about
a marijuana grower in Florida who was
found innocent or who was given a very
minor sentence under state law and then
was prosecuted for the same marijuana
under federal law and given a given a
life sentence it varies it entirely
depends on who arrests you who decides
to prosecute you and what they decide to
prosecute you for and one of the big
themes of this section is the amazing
increase in prosecutorial power as a
result because under federal law
marijuana is illegal in every state of
the Union in any amount so technically
the federal government could prosecute
anybody arrested for marijuana anywhere
in the United States in practical terms
they don't do that but if there's a
prosecutor who doesn't like you and
really wants to cause you a hard time
you can be in big trouble
even for you know relatively small
amounts of marijuana how many people are
in prison or jail today because of
marijuana very very hard to calculate
and the best estimate I could come up
with is about twenty thousand in federal
prison thirty thirty-five thousand in in
state prison and jail is very hard to
guess but a lot the the one area that's
looked at marijuana arrests for
possession just for simple possession of
marijuana and and who goes to jails in
Maryland they did a study and they found
that one out of every four people
arrested went to jail for at least a
night and one out of every six arrested
went to jail for at least a week and
that's a lot of people when you figure
the nationwide about 700,000 people are
arrested for pot every year and that's
more than for any other drug before we
run out of time I asked you about your
mother and father what about your own
family he married you have kids
I'm married and I have two kids how old
are they and they're 10 and 12 and I
look forward to the day when I let them
read one of my books so far my
daughter's maybe a year or so away from
that why is that this is these are very
disturbing subjects often I mean in Fast
Food Nation
you know the Meatpacking section is is
very is very graphic and and I think
very upsetting and you know I think I'll
wait a year or so before I want my
daughter reading about hardcore
pornography
what's your own attitude about your kids
as they grow up about all this fast
foods pornography smoking marijuana you
know I want them to obey the law I've
really seen the consequences of seeming
seemingly trivial offenses and how that
can destroy a life I mean if you're
caught with any amount of marijuana and
convicted of a misdemeanor you can have
student loans taken away for life so I'd
like them to obey the law but I'd also
like them to grow up questioning the law
and not just accepting the status quo
and and thinking for themselves
so you know try to give them a sound
moral foundation and then they're gonna
have to figure out these issues for
themselves this book as we read earlier
says that you're already at work on that
book on the American prison system I've
come out of all this it did it came out
of I mean I'd never been in a prison
before in my life before visiting
Leavenworth Penitentiary
I had to see mark Young locked up there
for pot and in looking at our drug laws
and in looking at the black market and
it really made me think about our prison
system and who's in prison and why and
and that's the next book when is that
gonna come out I've got a I've got to
finish writing it I'd say a year and a
half something like that and at this
stage in your career are you happy with
way things are going there's no novels
here these are all various books
absolutely no compliant to be able to
write about what you care about and to
get it published and you know what I'm
trying to do is make people think about
these issues so to the degree that there
can be a public discussion of them
because of what I've written
no complaints and on the first book
anything happened as a result of your
book Fast Food Nation any legislation
any I don't know I mean I'm I'm where to
claim any cosmic global credit for
anything that I've read and I've found
individual people that I've met have
told me that it changed their eating
habits or changed their view of things
and that's very gratifying I think that
a lot of the issues are dealt with in
Fast Food Nation are now part of the
public debate and maybe that would have
happened anyway but but that I feel it's
that that was very gratifying experience
our guest has been Eric Schlosser and
this is the cover of the book and is the
way we're showing it here at it's really
the right way except that if you know
how to read it I can turn it this way
and the book is called reefer madness
thank you very much for joining thank
you